hello my people on the Internet it's
super early so I apologize for my
appearance but I'm sitting here waiting
to uh watch and react to the new Zelda
direct we're three minutes till I'm
thinking what they might do is they
might just upload the video and then
Premiere it alright it's nine on the dot
yep not seeing anything let me see if
either of these two other Chads found it
like 10 minutes is a it's not much yeah
no it's not much it was a live stream I
think we're all wondering where the heck
it is right now oh there it is there it
is found it here we go
hello everyone hello I'm Aegis producer
of The Legend of Zelda series
it is early sir but it's good to see you
I have some news
development on the Legend of Zelda tears
of the kingdom is now complete okay
thank you for waiting yeah you're
welcome
to this game
and we've released a few trailers so far
although it'll just be a brief Glimpse
I'm going to actually play the game for
you okay and show you what it's like is
this another trailer drop
okay
let's begin let's begin thank you here
we are in the land of Hyrule
I like the Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild there's a vast world to explore of
course it's not just the same world as
is it's changed in many ways yeah
there's a lot of debris if we talk about
all of the changes today we'll run out
of time so we hope you'll seek them out
for yourself when the game launches oh
we'll be seeking them out as per this
footage in this game believe the vast
world of Hyrule look at his buttons
reaches High into the sky is y'all
notice the land mass is floating up
there we call them Sky Islands oh okay I
like Sky rule but you know that makes
sense
you're probably wondering something oh
look how do you get to the sky islands
when they're so high up there's a little
thing right here that's kind of grayed
out it's like if we take a little green
icon something's falling from the sky
do you see it
I wonder what that is let's head over to
it
it's like he's talking to kids oh wow
where the object fell
yeah I noticed this in the latest
trailer as well here it is oh wow that's
a little bit bigger let's use one of
Link's new abilities
this little thing is his powers up here
his hand powers
look it started Rising started reversing
hours known as recall which rewinds an
object's movement oh and that's the
simplest recall
I can now rise into the sky no you're a
lot closer to the sky islands
let's use the paraglider to reach one of
them
two other Sky Islands floating here too
so if you don't find something that's
falling
there are lots of ways to reach the sky
islands so we hope you'll try a few
different methods we're just not going
to talk about the dragon that's cool
okay now we're on a slightly bigger Sky
Island
just like on the surface there are
several man-made structures
you won't see many of those yellow trees
on the surface though
let's walk around okay that seems a
little telling
specifically Sky Island yellow trees huh
it might come in handy later
yellow leaf tree branch why is
everything golden up here
this is a brand new enemy called a
construct we'll fight it using the
branch we just picked up yeah please
don't break your Shields ah the weapons
are the same not good the weapons get
another branch and
we defeated it
so these things are made out of Zone I
charge we've now explored more
did you see them fighting with just a
branch won't get us very far that was
the first listen I'm freaking out it's
almost broken because that was the first
carbonation of Link's new abilities
everything is used
here and do this look we can stick them
together we created a makeshift Hammer
this is called fuse you can stick
objects together to create new weapons
with various I saw that he could stick
it on his Shields take on another
construct what is this
what the heck we're dealing with two of
them at once oh boy
does it do anything for your durability
oh we beat one yeah it looks like the
weapons attack has definitely improved
wow now it's like Oh wrong this weapon
has much better durability and now it's
like yeah much better you can do all
sorts of things by experimenting with
the fusibility okay that that is pretty
freaking cool you confuse two weapons
for example I still I'm sorry I can't
believe you stick and the zones are the
Pitchfork
we can create a weapon with a much
longer attack range
okay with this we don't I'm just gonna
be separate to enemies and we can safely
attack from a distance
that is cool as hell you can also fuse
Arrows with materials in your inventory
for instance we'll try using this Leaf
to an arrow fuse it with me you won't
you won't fuse it use an ice Elemental
material to an arrow and
you can freeze far away enemies
so have they done away with in addition
just Fire and Ice arrows and stuff you
have to make there's a bird flying
around if you're out hunting you might
feel that aiming with an arrow is too
difficult
track fast moving objects as of late so
my shots rarely land
age is about a number
here's an eyeball you can get by
defeating monsters
fuse it to an arrow and
oh that's how they did that
that's how they did that in the let's
try this on another bird
I'll just fire in that General Direction
that's very simple that is very cool
depending on what you stick together the
fusibility could also be beneficial for
hunting all these zonai powers
this mushroom is actually a Puffs room
let's fight an enemy with this oh
I blocked with the shield
okay there's smoke now
oh my goodness even if you struggle with
combat you can take down enemies using
similar methods oh my goodness in the
previous game you'd usually get powerful
weapons by defeating strong enemies
using even the weakest weapon with
something else just turn it into a
useful weapon there are even more
gameplay options for sticking things
together let me demonstrate
some of the sky islands even have Rivers
we'll want to cross this one and golden
swimming across it oh what's that power
look too white for the hand we need a
red hand what are you gonna do resembles
a boat around here
so oh here it is lift up this log and
it's almost to the second log
wait wait wait let's do one okay you're
making a raft
I see those pieces on the ground there
sir third log is that uh is that a
little propeller you gonna make a little
bow it's a makeshift raft another new
ability called Ultra hand
even though the logs are currently
attached they can be detached let's
modify the shape of the raft oh you see
it like what the heck you can always
attach things or detach them like this
why is this the coolest thing I've ever
seen now if we put this on the water
it's made of wood so the buoyancy will
keep it afloat
we've made a simplified version of a
boat
it won't move in its current state so
we'll need something to propel it
forward my goodness the Zone eye man
man there's something here let's try
hitting it
hi
oh a wind it's blowing wind
looks like we found a fan why don't we
try it talking to us like we're children
and I am I am all for it
we'll attach another one oh I see this
should make the boat well balanced I
thought he was gonna stick it in the
water
okay they're attached oh my goodness all
right let's try moving the boat you hit
them both
[Music]
okay oh my goodness look at this pretty
fast with the win from the fans
this is stupid it's so since we added
two fans we should be able to cross the
river in no time
turn the fans off sir we reached the
other side and turn the fans off
in the most recent trailer is that we
showed stomp stom bulb what was that oh
crap
in the most recent trailer we showed
scenes of Link riding a large car and a
flying machine get some stamina those
Vehicles actually aren't in the game
from the start to build they'll be able
to freely craft them on your own there
are all sorts of objects you'll come
across in this game and depending on how
you use your imagination where are you
going we do a lot with them so try
crafting different things and explore
this world at your leisure
oh my goodness there are even more new
abilities
take this building over here okay yes
please tell me about the freaking
buildings
okay what was that passed right through
the ceiling yeah what that's this one is
called ascend if you're in a place with
a ceiling you can go through
to the floor above you why did that one
take longer
there are some restrictions a little bit
more what's great about this ability is
that as long as there's a ceiling you
can use it anywhere wow wow so not like
a cave this place has a cave with a hill
right above it
if we use the Ability here
it's not gonna work
it won't do anything it is it's a
working oh come on keep going
okay we emerged at the top it doesn't
matter he just keeps going in the
previous game you had to use stamina to
climb a mountain but in this game if
there's a mountain with a cave like this
one it doesn't matter
here's another example imagine you're
stuck in a cage he's got a ceiling you
know what to do right exactly
some enemies are equipped with fused
weapons so battles will play out a bit
differently from the previous game
that is a paddle ah it's looking away
with wind
looks like it's got some sort of fan I I
want to make like an abusive parent joke
but uh ah I probably should I got pushed
off
oh well let's just return to the surface
yeah let's oh well why can't you recall
yourself from the sky to the surface
like this
it feels so good
your interest
once you've chosen your destination you
can speed things up like this
let's dive into this River it really did
just
and we're back on the surface by the way
there's no way he would have stopped
right there he would have smacked on the
bottom of that there's still so many
things I'd like to show you but let's
leave it at that for now oh my goodness
well thank you for that
it begs the question what how are you
what did you think
yeah I'm sure some of you watching me
play were thinking wait if you could do
that then maybe you could do this too
in this game you can do a lot of things
just by thinking about what's even
possible
there's still a lot of new gameplay
Mysteries and encounters we couldn't
show today but they're all product into
this unfamiliar Hyrule and we hope but I
appreciate you for nothing to explore
because we're only like 40 something
days that's all for today
thank you for watching oh my goodness
that was really really freaking cool and
oh no oh no oh
wait wait there it is it was real oh wow
I can't believe I was gonna click out
it's the Zelda OLED
is it
I want it I need it I have a day one
switch all of y'all nobody buy it until
I get it
oh it's gorgeous
oh
can I buy it now
can I buy it now oh my goodness gravy
it's so gorgeous I am so oh my goodness
I knew so the leak was real the leak was
real this is legitimately how the leak
looked and we knew it was real too
because these symbols here
those symbols showed up again in like a
trailer so I was like oh that had to be
real so I've got a man I've gotta
purchase this man but anyway this was a
really really really really really
really
revealing but yet not revealing in in
true tears of the Kingdom fashion
trailer and I can't not trailer but you
know what I mean and I can't wait to
actually like decipher it and see what
the hell was going on in each of these
frames here biggest takeaway the zonai
have been confirmed people not just
confirmed but like confirmed in a big
way all right and based on certain other
things that we may or may not know from
certain books that may or may not have
been leaked we know that the Zone I now
tie into all sorts of stuff the history
of the Legend of Zelda alright guys
thank you for um being here along with
me to see my reaction subscribe if you
haven't already to stick around for
analyzes and all sorts of coverage for
tears of the Kingdom that's come right
around the corner oh yeah and leave a
like on this video if you don't mind
that's it for today this is Bandit
looking forward to seeing you next time
and signing out peace
now I gotta press stop